JOINING US TO WEIGH IN ON ALL OF
THIS IS CHUCK SCHUMER, THE
DEMOCRATIC SENATOR FROM NEW
YORK.
SO GLAD TO HAVE YOU BACK ON SET.
BUT WE HAVE TO ASK YOU ABOUT
WHAT'S HAPPENING WITH THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL NOW APPOINTING
THE SPECIAL COUNSEL AND THE FACT
THAT THE WHITE HOUSE IS
ACKNOWLEDGING THESE CLASSIFIED
DOCUMENTS WERE FOUND.
DO YOU BELIEVE HE'S VIOLATED THE
FEDERAL LAW HERE?
>> IT'S TOO EARLY TO TELL.
THERE'S A SPECIAL PROSECUTOR IN
EACH SITUATION.
I THINK PRESIDENT BIDEN HAS
HANDLED THIS CORRECTLY.
HE'S FULLY COOPERATED WITH THE
PROSECUTORS WHEN THE DOCUMENTS
WERE FOUND, NOTIFIED AIED ARCHI
TOTAL CONTRAST TO PRESIDENT
TRUMP WHO STONEWALLED FOR A
YEAR.
BUT THE POINT IS WE HAVE SPECIAL
PROSECUTORS FOR BOTH OF THESE
SITUATIONS, WE SHOULD LET IT
PLAY OUT.
WE DON'T HAVE TO PUSH THEM IN
ANY DIRECTION OR TRY TO
INFLUENCE THEM.
THAT'S ALL I'M GOING TO SAY, LET
THE SPECIAL PROSECUTORS DO THEIR
JOB.
>> DO YOU SUPPORT THE FACT THAT
A SPECIAL COUNSEL IS OVERSEEING
THIS MATTER NOW?
>> YES, I DO.
IN FACT, WHEN THEY FIRST -- THE
FBI WENT TO MAR-A-LAGO AND THEY
SAID, WHAT ARE YOU GOING TO SAY
ABOUT THIS?
I SAID, IT'S PREMATURE TO
COMMENT AND I'VE SAID IT HERE,
SO I'VE BEEN CONSISTENT ABOUT IT
IN BOTH CASES.
YOU HAVE SPECIAL PROSECUTORS, I
SUPPORT BOTH OF THEM.
LET THEM DO THEIR JOB.
I THINK THAT'S ALL THAT SHOULD
BE SAID.
THE POLITICIANS SHOULDN'T BE
BUZZING AROUND.
TO BE SURE ABOUT WHAT YOU SAID,
YOU BELIEVE THE BIDEN FOLKS ARE
BEING TRANSPARENT ABOUT THIS?
>> I THINK THE BIDEN FOLKS, AS I
SAID, COOPERATED WITH THE
PROSECUTORIAL AUTHORITIES FROM
DAY ONE AND DONALD TRUMP DIDN'T.
>> THIS IS OUR REPORTING.
ACCORDING TO ONE JUSTICE
OFFICIAL STATEMENTS THIS WEEK
OFFERED AN INCOMPLETE NARRATIVE
OF DOCUMENTS FROM BIDEN'S TIME
AS VICE PRESIDENT REINFORCE THE
NEED FOR SPECIAL COUNCIL.
IT CREATES THE IMPRESSION THAT
BIDEN'S TEAM HAS SOMETHING TO
HIDE.
>> THERE'S NOW A SPECIAL
PROSECUTORS SEE WHAT THEY HAVE
TO SAY.
AND LET'S FOCUS ON DOING THINGS
THAT HELP THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
>> I HAVE TO GET -- I HAVE TO
SAY THIS.
YOU SEEM MUCH MORE MEASURED
ABOUT THIS THAN WITH THE TRUMP
DOCUMENTS BECAUSE YOU CALLED FOR
TRANSPARENCY WITH THE DOCUMENTS
YOU WANTED LAWMAKERS TO HAVE
ACCESS TO THE DOCUMENTS SEIZED
FROM THE FORMER PRESIDENT'S
RESIDENCE IN FLORIDA --
>> I SAID THAT NIGHT IT WAS
PREMATURE TO COMMENT.
I STAND BY THAT.
>> FOR PRESIDENT TRUMP?
>> YES.
>> YOU THINK YOUR STATEMENTS ARE
CONSISTENT FOR BOTH?
>> Reporter: I DO.
>> YOU SAY THE PRESIDENT HAS
FULLY COOPERATED.
THERE'S NO INDICATION THAT HE
AND THE WHITE HOUSE HAVE NOT BUT
THERE'S QUESTION ABOUT
TRANSPARENCY --
>> THE PROSECUTORS WILL GET TO
THE BOTTOM OF THIS AND LET'S LET
THEM DO IT FOR GOD'S SAKE.
I KNOW YOU WANT TO BUZZ
AROUND --
>> LET ME BUZZ FOR A MINUTE.
LET ME BUZZ FOR ONE MINUTE AND
WE'LL GET TO SOMETHING ELSE --
>> HOLD ON IT'S NOT JUST US
BUZZING YOU'RE THE HEAD OF THE
DEMOCRATIC SENATE IT'S NOT JUST
US BUZZING AROUND.
>> AND IF THERE WERE NO SPECIAL
PROSECUTOR YOU MIGHT HAVE A
DIFFERENT THING TO SAY, BUT
THERE IS.
NOW WE HAVE THE LAW ENFORCEMENT
PEOPLE WHO HAVE THE POWER TO GET
ALL THE FACTS OUT DOING IT.
I SUPPORT BOTH.
I THINK WE SHOULD HAVE A SPECIAL
PROSECUTOR ON EACH, I DON'T MIND
YOU ASKING THESE QUESTIONS BUT
MY VIEW, I'M NOT GOING TO SAY
ANYTHING, LET THE SPECIAL
PROSECUTORS DO THEIR JOB.
>> THE QUESTION I WAS GOING TO
ASK IS ABOUT THE FACT WHEN THIS
DID COME OUT, AFTER CBS NEWS'
REPORTING AND THE WHITE HOUSE
ACKNOWLEDGED IT, THEY ADDRESSED
THE DOCUMENTS FOUND ON NOVEMBER
2nd BUT KNEW ABOUT THE DOCUMENTS
FOUND ON DECEMBER 20th.
THAT'S WHAT BEGS THE QUESTION OF
FULL TRANSPARENCY IT'S NOT JUST
US.
IF THE PRESIDENT AND THIS WHITE
HOUSE ANSWERED MORE QUESTIONS
DIRECTLY LIKE THAT TIME LINE
THAT WOULD PROMOTE TRUST AND
PRE-EMPT THE CRITICISM.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO SEE THE WHITE
HOUSE DO THAT TODAY?
>> I LEAVE EVERYTHING UP TO THE
SPECIAL PROSECUTOR.
THEIR JOB WAS TO REPORT THINGS
TO THE NATIONAL ARCHIVES WHEN
THEY SAW THEM.
UNLIKE TRUMP THEY DID.
>> CAN WE TALK ABOUT CAPITOL
HILL.
>> YES, PLEASE.
>> WHAT HAPPENED ON CAPITOL HILL
LAST WEEK WITH SPEAKER McCARTHY
AND THE FIGHT AND 15 BALLOTS AND
THE CONCESSIONS HE MADE TO THE
HARD LINERS.
THEY SAID THEY DO NOT WANT TO
PASS A CLEAN SPENDING BILL.
THEY WANT CUTS ATTACHED TO THAT.
HOW ARE YOU GOING TO HANDLE THAT
IN THE SENATE?
>> WE ALWAYS TRY TO WORK WITH
THE REPUBLICANS IN A BIPARTISAN
WAY.
WE HAVE THE MOST SUCCESSFUL
SESSION SENATE IN DECADES IN THE
LAST YEAR.
AND SIX OF THE BIG SEVEN BILLS
WERE DONE BIPARTISAN.
SO I WOULD HOPE THAT HOUSE
REPUBLICANS, UNDER SPEAKER
McCARTHY, WILL REACH OUT TO US,
WILL REACH OUT TO THEM, AND TRY
TO GET THINGS DONE THAT CAN HELP
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
BUT THE PAST WEEK HAS BEEN VERY
DISCOURAGING.
WHAT DID THEY DO?
LET'S LOOK AT EACH OF THINGS
THEY DID.
NONE HELPED THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
THE FIRST THING THEY DID IS
PROTECT MULTIMILLIONAIRES AND
BILLIONAIRES FROM BEING AUDITED.
IT'S A LONG THRUST OF SOME OF
THESE MAGA REPUBLICANS THAT
PEOPLE SHOULD GET AWAY WITH THE
LOOPHOLES THEY USE.
SO FINALLY WE WERE ABLE TO SAY,
THE IRS IS SHORT OF PEOPLE
BECAUSE DONALD TRUMP CUT THE
PEOPLE, THE TEA PARTY CUT THE
PEOPLE.
>> A LOT OF PEOPLE ARE RETIRING.
>> YES.
BUT UNDER TRUMP YOU WERE MORE
LIKELY TO BE AUDITED IF YOU MADE
$40,000 A YEAR, THAN IF YOU MADE
4 MILLION A YEAR.
THE REPUBLICANS COME IN AND DO
THAT.
THEN THEY PUT IN A BUDGET THAT
WOULD REQUIRE US TO CUT SO MANY
THINGS.
THEIR TEN YEAR BUDGET WOULD CUT
MEDICARE AND SOCIAL SECURITY.
WOW.
THEN THEY PUT IN THINGS ON
ABORTION THAT WOULD ALLOW
DOCTORS TO BE PROSECUTED,
CRIMINALIZATION IN CERTAIN
INSTANCES.
AND THE FINAL THING THEY DID IS
LAUNCH A LOT OF COMMITTEES TO
INVESTIGATE.
YOU KNOW WHAT THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE WANT US TO DO?
THEY WANT US TO DO THINGS TO
MAKE SURE LIVES BETTER.
THEY DON'T WANT CONGRESS TO
INVESTIGATE, INVESTIGATE.
ONE FINAL POINT.
SO THERE ARE A WHOLE BUNCH OF
REPUBLICANS WHO ARE NOT MAGA.
MY HOPE IS, AND I BELIEVE THIS,
AFTER A LITTLE WHILE THEY WILL
SEE FOLLOWING THIS EXTREME
FRINGE IS LIKE FOLLOWING THELMA
AND LOUISE OVER THE CLIFF AND
THEY WILL COME AND START DEALING
WITH US IN A SERIOUS WAY.
WE'LL HAVE DISAGREEMENTS BUT IN
A PREVIOUS CONGRESS WE WERE ABLE
TO COME TOGETHER AND GET THINGS
DONE.
IF A REPUBLICAN PARTY REJECTS
THE MAGA EXTREMISTS WE CAN GET A
LOT DONE AND THAT'S MY HOPE.
>> DOES IT MAKE YOU REGRET NOT
RAISING THE DEBT CEILING BEFORE
THE REPUBLICANS GOT THE MAJORITY
IN THE HOUSE?
>> NO.
IT SHOULD BE DONE IN A
BIPARTISAN WAY.
TAKE THE DEBT CEILING.
TO LET THE DEFAULT OCCUR WOULD
HURT AVERAGE AMERICANS
DRAMATICALLY.
IF YOU WERE WORRIED ABOUT
INFLATION, WE'VE CUT THE DEFICIT
IN THE IRA, WE REDUCED THE
DEFICIT.
WORRIED ABOUT INFLATION, DEFAULT
WOULD BE HUGE.
SO IT'S ALWAYS BEEN DONE IN A
BIPARTISAN WAY.
THREE TIMES WHEN DONALD TRUMP
WAS PRESIDENT, TWICE WHEN THE
REPUBLICANS HAD THE HOUSE AND
SENATE WE COOPERATED WITH THE
REPUBLICANS AND RAISED IT.
BECAUSE AFTER ALL THESE ARE
DEBTS WE'VE ALREADY INCURRED.
WE'RE JUST PAYING THE BILL.
AND THEN UNDER PRESIDENT BIDEN
WE WORKED OUT AN AGREEMENT
BIPARTISAN WHERE THE REPUBLICANS
DIDN'T HAVE TO VOTE FOR IT BUT
THEY ALLOWED 50 VOTES TO PASS
IT.
AND WE GOT IT DONE.
THAT'S WHAT WE SHOULD DO AGAIN,
GET IT DONE IN A BIPARTISAN WAY.
THEY REJECTED THAT IN DECEMBER,
BUT I THINK, AS WE GET CLOSER
AND CLOSER, THE REAL -- THE WAY
WE HAVE TO DO THIS OR THE MONTH
WE HAVE TO DO THIS LOOKS THREE,
FOUR, FIVE, SIX MONTHS OFF, THAT
THEY WILL COME TO REALITY AND DO
THE SAME THING WE DID THE LAST
FOUR TIMES.